tout donne fondamentalement l'impression
que Kiev entame délibérément des négociations
groupe de contact à l'arrêt juste pour
détachez vos mains pour revenir
Donbass par des moyens militaires et
au fait, la confiance ukrainienne
le leadership de la possibilité d'une solution énergique
les conflits s'ajoutent par des incessants
fournitures d'armes avec les pays occidentaux
et munitions
et bien sûr le déploiement du nom militaire
missions de formation sur le territoire
pays et
dans la même tirelire et ici pour la qualité
exercices conjoints avec les pays de l'OTAN
faire appel à la capitale occidentale et qui
pomper l'ukraine avec des armes avant
juste washington well comme air berlin avec
paris en tant que participants à la Normandie
format arrêter d'encourager
militarisation du pays et utiliser leur
influence pour remettre Kiev sur les rails
parvenir à une paix durable dans le Donbass
la politique par voie diplomatique